exterior Cincinnati Ohio two women
speaking on a rooftop Terrace of a
high-rise building drayana Dunson I've
been through
foster homes
five group homes and five shelters five
different shelters in the past 13 years
Amia Berry my parents had recently had
got a divorce I would have like bad
thoughts and would end up actually here
in Cincinnati Children's a lot aerial
shot of Cincinnati Children's Medical
Center so that's when they decided that
it would be better for me to go to the
foster care system
Judith W dexheimer PhD associate
professor UC Department of Pediatrics so
there are about 470 thousand
s and of kids in foster care they have
disjointed Medical Care and when they
change placements or change to a new
Foster family they frequently change and
potentially lose their medical records
well your caseworkers drop you off they
don't give them the information that
they need they just let them know hey
got this child she's a female she's this
age and we'll be bringing her in do you
have any beds open so I applied for an
nlm Grant laptop displays nlm's website
text National Library of Medicine
extramural program because what the nlm
is trying to do with health disparities
and health disparities research fits
directly into what we want to do with
our care our goal was to start with the
kids who were 18 and over who are
eligible for or emancipating out of care
a man and woman are at a table working
with the health Hero app on a tablet and
help provide them with both their
medical records and a portion of their
data from job and family services so
from the people who have their actual
custody so they could see their records
they could see their major diagnoses
their current medications their
immunizations and then then they could
become stewards of their own data but
then they also headed in a form that
they could take with them as they
transition from pediatric to adult care
one of the reasons I use half hero was
to set up my appointment for my
pregnancy I did not remember all my
testing that I had done because I never
had like actual copy of my insurance
card so my insurance card was on there
and they can scan it and put it through
their system if you don't know your
information by heart it will be there
for you to remember and it just like it
helps it shows you more information that
you can learn outside of what people
tells you one of the great things about
doing the funding through the National
Library of Medicine is the primary focus
was how to build an application with the
end users involved in a novel way text
number one building app number two
distribution number three evaluation how
do you wait whether or not they used it
a feature on health hero that was
helpful to me was under immunization
records I was able to log in look at my
records and print it out to get into
nursing school I grew up in the hospital
and that made me want to become a nurse
because I would become very close to the
nurse I would just like to take care of
people for the rest of my life if I ever
get the chance it's important for youth
that's being emancipated to have health
hero because of the fact that it's just
something that you need to know it's
you're not going to always have someone
there that remembers all your
information
my advice to a person that was going
through what I went through is you never
give up you don't let the foster care
make you who you are
you always fight and you don't give up
you don't let the foster care Define you
you don't let it break you the gray and
blue nlm logo Fade up over a white
background with blue text serving
scientists and Society